damn
i'm hitting this money ball easy money
oh no you're not
game listen up everyone i'm michael
smith
taking on michael carter williams it's
the final challenge in mike's hard
lemonade seltzer's battle of the mics
nobody makes lemonade like mike's they
are the experts so today we're going
against each other to see which of us
mikes can make the most three-pointer to
be crowned the true expert
and five thousand dollars given to a
charity dedicated
to continue changing the game each shot
will get me a point
but if i'm ahead at the end i'm gonna
use the yellow money ball
to make a half court shot to win it all
money ball good let's get into it
oh my goodness
you did not make the money bro check the
tape honest to the tape
how many threes did you hit none oh man
no
no this is not fair money ball good
though no
no i feel honored i feel blessed i've
worked hard for this
blood sweat and tears so many trials and
tribulations you may not have won the
trophy mike
but you you know what i mean you won our
hearts mike man i'm not planning to sit
here and listen to this man i got my
custom championship belt
my custom championship trophy i want to
thank bleach report and mike's hard
lemonade seltzer for putting this
together
see y'all on the court he won't win next
year
i get to keep this belt